[Music]  brad pitt has a new movie coming out  this week and uh it's called killing  them softly and it's the first time  we've seen pitt since all the backlash  he got for doing the infamous ad for  chanel number five  yeah and uh i was curious i saw an  advanced clip from the movie i don't  know if brad's doing much  to help his image take a look  mickey  i felt like a man nick you made me feel  good what  it's not a journey  every journey ends but we go on  leave me alone  it turns when we turn with it  plans disappear  they kick a lot dreams take over  but wherever i go there you are my luck  my fate my fortune  i don't take orders from guilds number  five  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  he says that a lot in the movie